let's bring in dr. mark Siegel Fox News
medical contributor dr. Siegel I know
you have said that this is very
concerning he's 55 years old
Morris Johnson why are you why are you
so concerned if he's not on the
ventilator yet
well Angley why I'm not concerned is
because he's 55 and he's in good health
as far as we know no underlying medical
conditions and exercises a lot is known
as an exercise person all that is good
what I am concerned about is 10 days
after he first started having this he's
still having the persistent fever the
coffin the shortness of breath the
shortness of breath requiring oxygen
implies that there's lung involvement
going on here it's really good news that
he's not on the ventilator at this point
but we also look at the heart the kidney
the liver we look at all of the organs
in this kind of a situation and
especially the inflammation in the lungs
our hopes and prayers are with him the
fact that he hasn't gotten worse since
he's gotten into the ICU per your last
report could have something to do with
the fact that the ICU intensive care
unit is being used as a precaution in
this case it may just be a way to give
him closer and closer observation make
sure if we make sure and we see that
he's not on the ventilator that's going
to be a good sign yeah we'll see so
that's got people concerned a lot of
people thought to the fact that the
Queen came out and made a speech which
he almost made it didn't make never
makes before very rarely if it was in a
holiday they thought that she might have
known something but we'll see where that
goes let's talk about what Governor
Cuomo was saying yesterday for a couple
of days in a row now he talks about less
incubations less hospitalizations less
men and women going into icy use so it
looks like the curve is bending but in
the back of my mind I keep hearing the
Surgeon General say this week is pearl
harbor 911 what do I do believe
well Brian you should believe both we're
still not out of the woods yet and we're
seeing you know as you know over 400,000
cases in New York alone and with with
with the death rates starting to flatten
out that's a very good sign because
people can get diagnosed and then later
on get serious complications I think all
of the social distancing the
shelter-in-place
all of
the precautions we're taking are
definitely helping dramatically I think
that's very good news the other issue is
can we get more rapid testing that's
another thing Aynsley aunt mentioned at
the top that at NYU Langone my hospital
we're studying some treatments some to
decrease inflammation in the lungs
hydroxychloroquine is being studied
early in the game these treatments can
make a difference potentially social
distancing huge and can we figure out
who has this rapidly and separate them
out
I definitely think in New York we're
heading in the right direction as other
hotspots are emerging like in Louisiana
and Florida New York definitely appears
to be turning the corner slowly yeah you
know dr. Siegel it was two days ago that
dr. Burks said from the podium she said
you know don't go to the grocery store
don't go to the pharmacy and yesterday
she actually clarified fied and she said
she meant reduce the number of trips
consolidate only send one person from
your family and try to only go once
every two weeks if that is at all
possible that's really good advice if
you can wait two weeks yes if people
can't really wait two week weeks I think
the major issue here is to be conscious
of things to be conscious of how close
you are to people you know I think the
people out there need to understand that
with all of the asymptomatic spread
people that have this and don't know
about it that's why we're adding
additional precautions like wearing a
mask when you're close to people because
you might have it and not know it we
need people to be conscious of that it's
not about how often you go to the
grocery store it's what you do when you
get there are you being careful are you
again going home and washing everything
washing your hands are you are you aware
of who's next to you what they're doing
it's about staying aware dr. sacani you
mentioned in why you land gun medicals
medical school where you teach or where
you practice I'm at that hospital ken
Langone has been on our show a bunch I
know his story came from nothing and has
created this Empire giving so much money
to that Hospital Bill and Melinda Gates
are funding that hydroxychloroquine
trial at your hospital and then look
what they're also doing they're spending
billions to come up with these
facilities seven facilities to try to
find this vaccine so people are really
coming together and people who have made
a lot of money or giving back to this
country and it's just awesome to witness
that this is an email from Timothy he
says my daughter is a community worker
okay you want to comment on that I just
want to say that I know ken Langone is
in tremendous heart a great entrepreneur
and he's the right spirit of the country
at this time and and Bill and Melinda
Gates as well you're absolutely right a
time of entrepreneurship a time of
giving back it's it's the American
spirit absolutely ok let me get back to
that email this is from Timothy dr.
Siegel he says my daughter is a health
care worker she and her seven-year-old
daughter live with us should we
quarantine her in her room when she gets
home from work should she stay away from
her daughter fantastic question I'm more
interested in her staying away from you
the writer of the of the email because
you're older her as far as we know and
this applies also to your lovely
daughter Ainsley younger children are
not getting this or if they are they're
getting much milder cases but a health
care worker should be changing clothes
constantly should be semi quarantining
should be taking a shower when they get
home and they should be getting tested
frequently that's the most important
thing we are testing our health care
workers now so we can see if they've
been exposed to Cove at 19
they shouldn't be fully quarantine but
they should stay as separate as possible
yeah so far I think the standard test
still takes seven days to get back I
can't wait till we get that 15-minute
test and that's everywhere I don't know
how long that's gonna be I'm gonna go
back to the emails now yeah I hope so
I says there's been a lot of
back-and-forth about wearing mass what
do we do to protect our eyes goggles
well Brian there was a new study out
yesterday that emphasized that the masks
can be faulty and you have to wear them
in just the right way and and the closer
to a surgical mask the better and that
keeps you from spreading it to others
not we're not worried about other people
spreading it to you worried about you
could have it and not spreading it as
far as eyes are concerned the problem
Brian is we're always putting our
fingers in our eyes and that's probably
the number one
way we spread this so I want people to
be more conscious of that rubbing their
eyes and I want to add something that
we've never said something very simple
when you wash your hands wash your face
we always say wash your hands wash your
face because viruses live on your face
and you're always touching your face so
so be aware of that
wash your hands and wash your face hands
first gotcha all right doctor meanwhile
an email from Kathy she writes social
distancing seems to be working but what
happens when we get out and about again
won't the virus spread once again and
that's the worry you know when people
see that the you know we're on the
backside of the apex dr. Siegel they're
gonna go okay we're back to normal
not gonna work like that is it I have a
slightly different answer than a mentor
of mine dr. Tony Fauci on this who says
we have to keep the same degree of
social distancing in place until we get
a vaccine and I'll tell you what my
thoughts are a little different
I think the vaccine is going to be the
landmark that we need but in the
meantime we're learning good habits now
habits that we should take forward but I
really want you to understand that if we
know who has this virus who is immune to
this virus who can go back to work who's
still sick that's going to be able to
help us decrease the amount that we're
using the draconian measures because if
we knew you're immune you can't you're
not going to probably not going to be
able to get it again if we knew you have
it social distancing is not enough
you've got to be quarantined that's why
I keep harping on the rapid testing so I
think we can decrease the amount of
draconian measures the more we know who
has it and who's immune okay so you go
great to see you this morning thank you
so much